well okay we're starting it here guys
staying here I just try to [ __ ] in there
some online [ __ ] and of course it
doesn't work because there's no like it
doesn't work no okay i don'ti the fast
Joe if i could i get as I got stuff yeah
I did ah Hank this baby needs a new
spark plugs or she ain't goin nowhere
yeah what's up a nectar Shane Oh to hell
of a car a battalion of those freaks
with a slow this baby down so if you can
find me a few necessary parts are made
in nearby wrecked car what a weird guy
I'll let you take her up and he was
coughing so much deal yeah sure do you
locate those parts you know where to
find me
okay yeah thank you now who's like
diarrhea yeah [ __ ] is dying there what
remember me mate on the doctor but I
can't do much without medical supplies
the door to the infirmary is locked from
the other side it ends in critical
condition you think he can't leave break
the bloody thing down yeah yes yes sure
thing I appreciate go on in oh oh I see
something Oh God get back down yes
sucker Oh No she's floating ice seen the
sea heart oh yeah now's my time to shine
can I get over here yes yes yes yes I
like that
that's good that's good after they get I
can't get off of that after that I guess
what I gotta pay for this stuff good on
you might only get to work that's Isaac
dad can I like that I guess Kelly's
worried about her husband will but I
think he's probably okay that's outside
be nearby there you see you when it's
with the hair design is just scraping in
hair show his name is William he's about
six foot one black hair good-looking
he's a concierge he has a friend named
Doyle who works in the diamond district
bungalows i'm thinking maybe he's hiding
out there you scraping your hair ok
down with James yes I ran out in such a
rush I love mom necklace behind at the
hotel it's in bangalore 6 in a silver
section them gave it to me it means a
lot to me i'm offering a reward can you
help me ah yes i guess i can give you a
hand thank you please be careful yeah
there's like a thousand points on right
now this don't sit don't playing there's
and let's check a quest okay
hmm which one has the most XP Oh Edgar
below but what the heck who's Dominic oh
it's above that's why okay okay let's
see now I see now okay okay easy yo says
he goes I'm domick this piece of [ __ ]
antennas too weak to reach past the
island we need a signal amplifier to cut
through the stat I worked on an antenna
at the Lighthouse nearby I'm sure they
got an amplifier there you wouldn't last
a minute against those things for you of
course of course I think I can help all
right excellent you bring it back as
soon as you can
okay let me just make sure that is
turned on
okay okay let's do this let's steer this
so we had a very slow start of course
like all things very bad channel okay
we're not going to go do this yes I keep
the strategy that stuff and you know you
know how I'm going to be can I be like
Ted question at once
oh yeah
get all the copper check here I know
where is a guava got that yeah yeah he
is toast okay yeah toast wings okay
get-get out what there's a four cars I
think so we got two so far it's good
not until I say it's done yes yes okay
what I always or is that are here I can
I take this
and there we had any cars now here are
the cars car park yeah
they get all the car parts yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh I think it happens if
my stand I was like too far down
okay okay now as you could say this
isn't going as why I'm job this a
Corrupter here and this guy equipped I
here
how do i use controls controls controls
and kept at each each okay all right I
guess I have none
this is not going so well for me Oh
had he turn this thing off
write down that
Jesus I figure here [ __ ] okay now what
can I use bandages can I use this
headache pain killers how do i use this
okay i guess i'm just not using it
what's this here okay i am still not
doing too well she says and it's tougher
to drink she says
ok
silver bungalows not sure that one lady
was okay hopefully there's a food here
can I jump over this yeah take this
heavy pipe can take that baseball bat
[ __ ] we're gonna knock out all this [ __ ]
out once okay nice [ __ ]
but I drinks in there so I'm just going
for it
it's always worth taking a look good i
was terrible okay lemon juice good you
thing in here now
okay okay methyl in here come in here
okay take this energy drink yes okay cat
cat cat painting here that I could take
you like stories for later ok I guess I
get get out of here what single bungalow
11
okay okay now scale skills no luck
how we need that step thank God okay
inventory thank God okay
yeah okay oh [ __ ] this fish get kids
open the guy what it knows open those
since I doesn't know
Lana's I use a lot of zombies in this
area okay I get into here though I guess
that's just not a place I can go into
well i'll just activate that one
question quest to cute cute request
queue for quest
okay get it how do I get in there hat
there's anyone that high how that I
could get get get hi Jessica I can't
yeah I get there no [ __ ]
oh I forgot him on the left side
I'll I heard some bitchin I IP he's my
husband he's eating can you help us oh
yes say say yeah bet ya by a Georgia
brothers and this is my wife Jess we
were driving with a better than hell
when I saw that broke down her father me
said who care about it but I couldn't I
couldn't do that Olivia to myself so we
stopped to see if we could help the
travelin was living in in shock or
something good he threw himself at us
like a crazy guy I had to had to kill
you well again I was protecting myself
you gotta believe me but you know what
he took a fight over me man that [ __ ] I
think I got what if he had a rabies I
don't know [ __ ] who the hell knows what
can you get this out of here if I start
to lose it I don't own the bloody hard
huh Asher Asher amen thanks [ __ ] to get
little Lighthouse my brother team should
be there ok kid yeah you don't like too
hot nice kill him
as if unless this is below six I gotta
get that necklace though then I how boys
[ __ ] the food it's just alcohol what
the [ __ ] is that red line oh now there's
a necklace ok ok let's go [ __ ]
it's are you gonna get in ok again oh
wow this is a good game
can I go this way
no no we're gonna find out man let me
tell you i am not used to driving on
these roads okay that is something I'm
not used to can't tell for going around
where it out now I might come back on
our way wait just horny set to go to the
lighthouse I'll shut yep I head
lighthouse that's this way
you
I got to get a lighthouse any way to get
that part so i might as well just do it
ok
oh it's actually a big place oh [ __ ]
yeah Jesus this seems like pretty insane
I had Rihanna [ __ ] together eyes for me
which I kills many stuck as I can on the
meantime
Jesus
take it get get that looks like we
[ __ ] aight it mm-hmm yah sansar l no
no no alright switching to write yes
okay when we were like Jesus give up now
games first he's the one in charge hmm I
love surprises
okay how does that hasn't happened I say
so you don't know me that I shall
remember you me and cinema had a slight
difference of opinion he wanted to stay
put and wait for help I wanted to get
the hell out of there so I got the hell
out I'm sure absolutely if you want to
get off this hour with the rest of us go
talk to my people see what you can do to
help okay yes sure I know a sigma thing
dead gay kid how do i had i get away
from you sir
I'm approaching the Mohegan store and to
meet my form like a cinnamon is crew
will not content to sit my butt as he
opposed to the couple shipwrecks the
resultant at month signifiers I can get
definitely good what help finally does
get here thank you thank you thank you
me to help that well it's okay
my name's Linda she got beat up pretty
bad after a gentleman he was in bandages
I think I happening killer thank you
that is exactly what I needed thank you
you just saved this girl's life here I
come
I was in contact with the pilots that
playing at window I really lose contact
with them after that but if they landed
that really hey that plane might be our
ticket out of here Thanks I won't you
look at your own Tonya it's okay let's
see here
okay so we follow james to this
lighthouse we can send out an SOS signal
using the live that's good pickles to
Jake the true transformers power in the
lighthouse but he's been gone for hours
someone needs to see what's happened
over and try to get the power back on
those things can't do to you what they
can do to us maybe you can help us share
share absolutely all right good look I
get it but I'm still trying to get this
antenna dinner over at that
the lighthouse warehouse okay at the
warehouse I get in there
hanky did I have to find Maggie looking
for me oh I wish you could you please
tell them that if you see him okay
those passengers if they're alive
Brad yes yes this I love up yes I did
guess I debt weird I hell did I put that
where's the warehouse look it up grades
up grades page here cos nobody locks
what is this okay good good wow this
exactly what I needed okay ah inventory
have a shitton now it's good quest
I can't just to go in there so all there
around something is right here let me
talk to my people I gotta go in here
somewhere
you can't get in there what the heck
you're gonna help Darvin Jesus hey hey
darvin Wow ok that's so much easier I
don't know if I'm ready to do that yet
no but what if I take a good car [ __ ]
keep forgetting that it's like it's
different over here ok in the last cuz
we're gonna do real quick is my precious
account here okay
nice time ago this way yes it's over
there is this ad crazy hard would it
oh [ __ ] this gonna be bad in it this is
gonna be bad
I don't even hear zombies the three
notes [ __ ] bad up there some over
there this is what then okay
because huge this guy is huge oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and debt
figure 2 weapons eka dza for weds worth
taking a look who
ok good get gettin I think I'm prepared
to fight this dude now there's a there
he is up [ __ ]
ok
oh Jesus electrics crap
how she actually chocalate
of course it's like all the way at the
end time
this guy's dad I not oh wait you're not
everything is so [ __ ] up on these
half-dead [ __ ] the [ __ ] I need more
champagne I [ __ ] love champagne let's
talk like a champ in that that no thanks
you like it I'd hear from russia with my
[ __ ] boyfriend oh thank you to find
me I can't believe that crazy [ __ ] yes
yes it's going to hell in the last
person I would take the money on
whatever else you however I'm dead
a lot of cash actually
okay it's a lot of money here Jesus ok
so there's nowhere to fast travel okay I
gotta go all look back up that hill
Jesus he just smoked guy get our run
back oh yeah ok so we're dress fine
nice beautiful though
okay i'm a time beach now see I get the
hell out of here I think so it's a kind
of like far cry actually don't know what
the hell this is not as with us okay
good good you suspect that on the air
one
so there's a secret cove in that no it's
not all right now I guess it's gone this
way cuz i'm just doing sprints uphill
right son [ __ ] products carry on [ __ ] by
mia remember there's like a not appear
yeah there's a desert okay
no I think I was like doing some short
[ __ ]
hey I gotta talk to this dead with your
help we're gonna get this lighthouse up
and running in no time
you're [ __ ] all right you get here
this fast travel where's that map
there's a map around here a map around
here others ah yes
feel what these boxes why smell that
yeah yeah oh great now maybe later sorry
Mike thanks thanks Jay hundred get a
check my gut there's a bit just like
diarrhea why angry skirt and thanks a
lot of space that's in a belly it's a
vicious [ __ ] Carver all done okay
poor son of a [ __ ] I thought he'd make
it um nice you found her they're still
here [ __ ] it then I'm out it
take a dead
uh-uh frame rate seems to be dropping
can't beat a good nothing here and old I
need you to locate an ambulance a one of
the life hi so on sure thing that your
help we'd all be 60
that's either anything up there okay
nothing up here okay let's see here haha
sir was I've ever now but they still
what to do go talk to them and see what
you can do
okay I guess we're just gonna end it
right there um let's see what quick what
we got to do this is conditioning if it
guys will [ __ ] nude oh that's good
Jesus
whoo that's what I need
this one que les
how bad
Mike and Dominic
Jesus up that's all for now